so I hope that by now many of you have
had a chance to see my interview with
Lex Friedman on his podcast it's about
three and a half hours long if you
haven't we've linked to it on the Press
page at davidpackman.com you can find it
on Lex's YouTube channel it's on his
audio podcast check it out if it's
interesting to you one of the things
that came up and generated a lot of
discussion is the discussion about
wokeness and to some degree as a
relation in relation to that cancel
culture and I want to delve into cancel
culture here a little bit more because I
think that it has become untenable to
continue even for a second pretending
pretending that the cancel culture is
prevalent anywhere other than the
American right wing now I know that some
of you will say but David hold on a
second it's the right wing that has been
messaging for years now we are against
cancer culture we're against
cancellation we're against all of that
stuff it is the left that cancel cancel
cancels like with most of these things
it is the height of projection from the
American right wing it is they accusing
the left of that which they are guilty
of themselves they say we're against
business regulation we're against it all
except when they want to force Twitter
to publish their covet nonsense all of a
sudden now Twitter should be forced
to publish kova disinformation or
businesses
if you want to require a mask you
shouldn't be allowed to do it new law
you can't require masks if that's what
businesses want to do rather than
letting the free market decide I'm aware
of bookstores that to this day require
masks and I'm aware of people that
choose not to go to those bookstores
because some people are over the masks
that's everybody's Choice nobody's
interfering I thought that was the way
that the right wanted regulation done
okay that gets us to cancel culture
think of the framing from the right
Wingers which is we will not let the
left keep canceling the left or the
cancellers blah blah blah blah blah the
book Banning movement the height of
cancellation growing and growing and
growing and it is the right that is
Banning books which is a form of
cancellation they are creating law
to restrict the phrases terms and topics
that teachers should be allowed to use
or better said should not be allowed to
use that's an insane form of
cancellation they want to cancel Disney
because Disney supported the don't say
gay bill they want to cancel M M's
because one of them was androgynous or
whatever that was crazy they want to
cancel Bud Light because Bud Light did a
promo with a trans woman
and all of it over choices that
businesses are simply making they're not
against the law they don't create any
legal issue Colin Kaepernick knelt
during the national anthem and then was
involved with Nike they wanted to cancel
Nike because Colin Kaepernick was in a
Nike ad and in fact they wanted to
cancel the NFL at one point because
people weren't standing during the
national anthem they wanted to pull
Public Funding for stadiums uh the NBA
they wanted to cancel because the NBA
has gone to woke with Dr fauci it's
cancel arrest in prison some even said
execute fouchy execute fauci someone
went as far as to say because fauci
was too arrogant or something about
medical knowledge meanwhile they were
listening to Trump's medical advice Liz
Cheney cancel she's the wrong type of
Republican there's no room for her
cancel her Republican credentials she
can't be in the Republican Party kick
her out other Republicans who simply
don't believe Trump won in 2020 Mitt
Romney cancel him as well they want to
silence people who are woke on Twitter
they want to cancel drag shows that
aren't being forced upon anybody it's up
to parents do you bring your kids to a
drag show or don't you by the way the
other day this is the season now for
Pride parades and I ended up wandering
through a couple Pride parades over the
last few weeks and uh I I laughed to
myself as drag performers came by or you
know but all sorts of different things I
laughed imagine seeing this you know I
had my baby daughter with me imagine
seeing this and thinking oh my goodness
Shield her from this this could this
could damage her this could ruin her in
some way it's Bonkers stuff but they
want to cancel all of it black lives
matter definitely deserves to be
canceled as well
how did these folks become such
snowflakes afraid of everything and
wanting to invoke in so many of these
cases the power of the state the power
of the state not in all but in many of
these cases the power of the state to
control and to cancel as well so we have
to really understand that if you zoom
out I've been telling you for a while
now they've essentially abandoned policy
because they're losing on policy they're
they're running on anti-abortion the
country mostly wants abortion to be
legal their wishy-washy on gay marriage
and sometimes completely against it the
country wants gay marriage to be legal
by a large majority they're running on
don't tax rich people the country by and
large thinks taxing the very rich to
fund social programs is a good idea
they're running on do nothing about guns
when more than 80 percent of the country
says at least pass a background check
law that doesn't let any transaction
circumvent requiring a background check
even transactions between people who
know each other they're running against
that they're off on all of the policy so
they go well the left wants to cancel
but really it is they who want to cancel
don't fall for it don't fall for it